françois darabont il est médecin
généraliste celle vue d'ailleurs
[Musique]
françois darabont bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin alors
vous êtes à 170 km au sud-ouest de
budapest je vais pas prononcer le nom de
vaudeville risquerais de me tromper mais
vous allez nous le dira en tout cas voir
arriver des vaccins russes et chinois
pour vous c'est une bonne chose pour le
médecin le médecin que vous êtes dans la
gestion de la crise bonjour à tous et je
vous remercie pour l'invitation
oui je tousse un grand chose et nous
apprécions beaucoup les efforts déployés
par notre gouvernement de procurer des
vaccins nous avons la peau de la
confiance en nos scientifiques et nous
avons de la confiance aussi dans les
vaccins luce
moi j'ai 55 ans et j'étais vacciner
pendant toute ma jeunesse avec des
vaccins russe en outre je les trouve
très bonne chose
alors du coup qu'est ce que vous
pourriez dire aujourd'hui à vous à vos
confrères européens on le voit dans
d'autres pays qui sont un peu plus
sceptique 1 par rapport à ces vaccins
russes et chinois j'ai repensé de l'ex
ministre max est aussi nationale
possible de les acheter et de l'upv
c'est pourquoi parce que quelqu'un
qu'elle différence finalement ces
vaccins on compte il par rapport à ceux
administrés en ce moment dans le reste
de l'europe
il ya une différence dans les
compositions de bach saint pasteur les
vaccins des restes de deux parcelles sa
contiennent un message est parrainée par
aîné qui est incluse dans une particule
de ripper tandis que les vaccins russe
utilise comme vecteur adénovirus à
l'auteur qui bat 2010 plus précisément
mais c'est aussi une technologie très
très moderne les accepter les processus
de fabrication a été vérifié par un
groupe de médecins ont grâce qui s'était
déplacé un look très réussi
dans la fabrique de vaccins pour étudier
les processus de vaccination et nous
autorités sanitaires ils ont déclaré que
le vaccin est tout à fait fiable et sans
danger n'est pourtant qu'une bouchée
alors autour de vous notamment chez vos
patients l'arrivée de ces vaccins ce
qu'il suscite de la crainte ou davantage
d'espoir j'ai plus que ça susciterait
davantage de l'espoir bien sûr qu'en
partie des populations a des doutes mais
mais elle ne fera oublier que pendant
les années 1960
nous étions tous vaccinés avec des
vaccins russe alors la population en
grand sur que ces habitués avec les
choses plus avec des maxi russe au
niveau de la situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui vous en ai tout en hongrie
au niveau des contaminations au niveau
des hôpitaux comment est-ce que cela se
passe en ce moment
heureusement les cas les nouveaux cas
d'infection est autant que les l'ombre
mauvaise heureusement je prends que ce
grasser grâce aux mesures imposées par
le gouvernement maintenant la situation
a commencé à s'améliorer et le système
sanitaire s'est organisée à céder
regrouper beaucoup de beaucoup de
soignants compter l'on peut regrouper
pour pour les intéristes ils les ont
reçu un certain 17 ans instructions pour
qu'il puisse travailler en 1 section de
soins intensifs
alors beaucoup de travailleurs
sanitaires ont été regroupés afin qu'on
puisse faire face aux pandémies
je trouve ça bien organisé se déroule
assez bien et au niveau de la stratégie
vaccinale comment cela se passe
aujourd'hui il ya des publics
prioritaires
oui il y en a un public prioritaire
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pour
reçu deux files et des modernes à
l'univers du vaccin dont nous avons
attendu si tout se passait normalement
déjà après demain et elle aurait fallu
que nous commencerons de vacciner la
population plus âgée
parce que dans les villages ils seront
la médecine de famille qui seront la
vaccination pour la population et mais
malheureusement le plan doit être
révisée et de faire parce que je dis ça
on ne pourra pas recommencer
on nous avons évolué pour des vaccins
merci vous passez en soi darabont
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin en direct
dans la matinale de france je le
rappelle vous de ça vous êtes médecin
généraliste en hongrie